jack dorsey sold an nft last year his
first ever tweet he sold it for 2.9
million dollars the person who bought it
held on to it for a year and then
announced last week that he was going to
be selling it online again he said i
decided to sell this nft the world's
first ever tweet and donate 50 of the
proceeds 25 million or more to the
charity at give directly obviously he
thinks that the tweet was going to go
for 50 million dollars because he said
he's going to donate 50 of the proceeds
25 million or more the auction ended
earlier this week and instead of getting
48 49 50 million dollars which he
previously spoke about getting he got
280 dollars i mean that is all time
i'm sorry but i'm gonna say it jack
fleeced them yeah jack fleeced them
because i you know this is going to
happen a lot with these nfts twitter
added the nft function they did all this
stuff but it's very clear that jack's
focus is bitcoin you know i mean his
focus is very very very very very
specific and it's bitcoin he said that
numerous numerous times and at the end
of the day i think what happened is he
sold the tweet right it was this cool
thing where people were auctioning off
tweets he auctioned off his first ever
one saw an avenue he got 2.9 million
dollars with it and again credit a lot
of places weren't reporting this but
your boy reported it because hey you
gotta be fair you gotta be fair don't
want people coming after jack he got 2.9
million dollars he didn't keep it though
he did not keep the money he did not
profit from the tweet he converted to
bitcoin and immediately donated it to uh
some countries in africa and some
organizations in africa that were doing
work for kova 19. important note there
and then the guy tried to sell it for
280
again i think that this is just a case
of like this tweet probably wasn't worth
much in the beginning anyways and and
maybe i don't think he actually ended up
selling it yet he kept the auction open
and he's trying to get more for it now
and i saw earlier this morning actually
that the
the tweet was uh
going for more now maybe a thousand
dollars or something like that but he's
not getting 48 million for it he's not
getting 50 million for it it's very
clear that this nft was not worth uh
what he expected it to be worth and he
ended up losing a lot of money on it
three million dollars or whatever it
ends up being so kudos to jack for
donating the money making sure that he
was taking care of people and and
helping others out uh but ultimately
like i think this is just kind of a
troll job it's it's funny to look back
on and be like uh yeah wait obviously
that tweet that's on the internet that
everyone can see that has no
significance at all relative to
everything else uh was not worth three
million dollars and it certainly wasn't
worth 48 million dollars what do you
think about it uh highest bid right now
is just over 12 grand right so when you
list something for 48 000 and sells for
its high bid is just under 12 grand a
little surprising but yeah i think this
is just a classic example of something
is only worth what someone's willing to
pay for it right so when you buy
something for 2.9 million that does not
mean that it is worth 2.9 million
dollars that just means that you are
willing to pay for 2.9 and the guy was
willing to accept 2.9 million dollars
for that item right um and then when you
hold it for a year i think this is what
we're gonna see a lot with the nfts is a
lot of these projects that gain a ton of
traction um they're just not sustainable
right they're almost gaining too quickly
that sounds weird to say uh but they
just don't have the right foundation for
this kind of environment and i think
we're gonna see a lot of these kind of
explode like this right and it's almost
it's almost like a self-rug pull because
no one actually rug pulled it but you
bought the item and when you went to go
sell it there wasn't a market to sell it
for anymore right so that's a big big
difference and i love jack surely
because he uh he had a nice snide at the
guy when the guy was like i'll donate 50
of the proceed he's like why not donate
all of it dude like come on like i think
he did come back and say that he was
gonna donate more more maybe a hundred
percent or or more but he was at least
saying 50 and then he he upped it and he
said he was going to donate more uh so
to his credit again i don't want to act
like he's some guy that's just trying to
make 50 million dollars on an nft he was
going to donate it et cetera um it's
unfortunate for him like he bought an
nft thinking that it was going to retain
the value and it clearly did not over
the course of a year that investment
maybe hangs on to it maybe it's worth
more in the future um but it was just
kind of unfortunate and you know what it
really is it's like one of those digs
that the non-nft people love
i which which
you get right i get it nft people are uh
are screaming aloud on the internet you
know what i saw the other day there is
uh there's a tweet i'll find it later
but this this nft account tweeted out
and they were like however many eth uh
scottie scheffler made for winning the
masters after putting in 25 years of
work and becoming the best player in the
world and then it was like however many
if my friend made for investing in uh or
minting a board ape and holding onto and
doing absolutely nothing and it was like
more than
scheffler made at the masters and i'm
like this is why people don't like you
this is literally why people do not like
you uh and not this person specifically
but just like the nfc thing in general
because again it's fun it's whatever i
think i don't know if he was joking it
didn't really sound like he was joking
um or she was joking but at the end of
the day that that's the stuff that
people don't like and i think that this
was another dig at that people have the
opportunity to look at it and say oh
look this guy lost a lot of money he
thought this entity was worth something
obviously it's not worth that much money
you're an idiot uh but also i think what
he was doing was he he was trying to
anchor that price a little bit he said
you know it's 48 50 million dollars
that's what it's worth maybe he gets 25
million maybe he gets 20 million maybe
he gets 10 million but i think he
thought he was going to get more than he
originally paid for it otherwise he
probably wouldn't have paid for it yeah
yeah so um again this is kind of like a
joke but at the end of the day like make
fun of whatever you want i i don't think
it's uh probably worth the time right i
think that your time is probably better
sure of figuring out other things or
looking into other things what are you
doing what do you do if you're him
if you're in you bought a item for three
million dollars and it's currently being
valued at 12 000 on the open market i
think you hold it i think uh i think you
hold it yeah if i own that yeah i would
hope yeah you're just like damn it
dude you guys spend three million
dollars at this point it's worth twelve
million twelve thousand based on the uh
current bid free market has decided it's
actually the free market has decided
that you're an idiot uh and they want
you to uh hold on to it for 12k hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time